ya hemos visto a los alcoholes muchos de
estos vídeos pero me pareció que ya era
hora de hacer un vídeo de alcoholes
de a
coles
ahora alcoholes es un término general
para toda molécula que cumpla con el
patrón
y algún tipo de grupo funcional o cadena
de carbonos
h
y usan la letra r y la he usado antes la
r significa radical
no quiero que confundan esta r con
radicales libres significan cosas
completamente distintas
r en esta forma sólo significa un grupo
funcional o una cadena de carbonos aquí
no significa radical libre esto sólo
significa que puede haber algo unido a
este o hd aquí
ahora otro punto que hay que aclarar es
que no vayas a pensar que todo lo que
cumple con este patrón es bebible no lo
asocie con el alcohol tradicional al
cual pudiste o no haber estado expuesto
ya el alcohol tradicional bebible el
alcohol tradicional
y alcohol
alcohol es de hecho etanol este alcohol
es de hecho y déjame escribo la fórmula
molecular ch3
h 2 y luego
h esto es lo que está dentro del vino y
la cerveza y el licor o lo que sea que
bebas y no te gustaría beber y puede que
tampoco te guste beber este pero
definitivamente no quieres beber algo
como metanol podría matarte así que no
quieres hacer algo como esto
no quieres ingerir
no puede matarte o dejarte ciego este
puede hacerlo en una manera más
indirecta y quiero dejar esto fuera por
ahora y ahora quiero que nos sintamos un
poco más cómodos con los alcoholes y los
hemos visto involucrados en otras
reacciones hidróxidos núcleo filos
reacciones de sustitución crean
alcoholes pero lo que quiero hacer ahora
es ya sabes sentirnos más cómodos y
realmente estar seguros de que sabemos
cómo nombrarlos así que solo nombremos
estas moléculas que dibujé antes de
comenzar a grabar así que por aquí como
en todo lo demás siempre queremos
encontrar la cadena más larga de carbono
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 carbonos así que será
venta así que sera
tal
y no hay y no hay doble enlace por lo
que es un venta no solo escribiré mental
y sólo escribiré pintan porque el hecho
de que sea un alcohol tiene prioridad
sobre el hecho de que sea un arcano por
lo que de hecho el sufijo de la palabra
incluye a la parte del alcohol así que
es ventanal y déjame hago eso el pentã
gono eso nos dice que es un alcohol y
para saber en dónde está el grupo
hidroxilo vamos a empezar a numerar
desde el borde más cercano a este
entonces es
5 así que esto y algunas veces va a
llamarse dos ventanas y esto está
bastante claro así porque sólo tenemos
un grupo hidroxilo aquí sólo un h por lo
que sabemos a qué se refiere el número
dos pero muchas veces la gente quiere
ser un poco más particular y podrían
escribir
ten
2 2
y esta manera es más útil especialmente
si tienes múltiples grupos funcionales
porque de esta manera sabes exactamente
en dónde están está de aquí es más
difícil de nombrar dos ventanas es
bastante directa
ahora intentemos nombrar esta esta esta
bestia de aquí tenemos un par de cosas
sucediendo aquí este es un alquilo es un
chino
tenemos un triple enlace es un alquilo y
tenemos dos grupos de bromo aquí y
también es un alcohol y el alcohol tiene
prioridad sobre todos ellos así que
queremos empezar a enumerar desde el
extremo más cercano al alcohol así que
queremos empezar a enumerar desde este
extremo de la cadena de carbono y
tenemos uno
8 carbonos así que estos serán este es
un ok
este es y queremos llamarlo ok sí no
pero ya que tenemos un alcohol aquí
queremos llamarlo octano oct déjame lo
escribo más claro entonces oct nos dice
que tenemos 8 carbonos y ahora tenemos
que especificar dónde está el triple
enlace el triple enlace está en el
quinto carbono siempre específicas el
número menor entre los carbonos del
triple enlace entonces es ok
[Música]
y no
eso nos dice dónde está el triple enlace
y luego tenemos el h en el cuarto
carbono entonces es 44 él
y luego tenemos estos dos grupos de
bromo en el séptimo carbono entonces es
7 es 7
sí
promo
de dromo
oct 5 14 hoy y todo esto es una sola
palabra déjame me aseguro de que se note
que esto está conectado y simplemente me
quedé sin espacio y eso probablemente es
la manera más confusa de nombrarlo pero
es solo para mostrarles que estas
moléculas pueden nombrarse
ahora pensemos en este verde de aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 carbonos así que va
a ser un ex y de hecho solo tiene
enlaces sencillos por lo que es un ex
ano es un ciclo hexano pero luego por
supuesto el hidroxilo debería de
llamarlo el grupo hidroxilo domina por
lo que es es un examen así que esto es
un
no
ciclo
y una vez más una vez más eso viene del
1 h de allí y no tienes que enumerar lo
porque no importa en qué carbono está si
tuvieras más de estos grupos hidroxilo
entonces nos tendríamos que preocupar
por numerar los ahora encontremos
hagamos este de aquí así que una vez más
cuál es nuestra cadena de carbonos
tenemos
3 carbonos y tenemos al grupo hidroxilo
unido al carbono número 1 y al 3 por lo
que esto va a ser nuestro prefijo es
prop es un arcano así que llamaremos
esto llamaremos esto y hay varias
maneras de hacer esto podríamos llamar a
esto 1 coma
eres
no
aquí tenemos a la o porque tenemos a la
de ahí entonces es propano de oro si no
fuera de él sería propanol no tendrías
la ocde y la hija y ésta es mejor tienes
en el carbono 1 y en el 3 al grupo
hidroxilo oh esto también puede
escribirse como
pero
pero para no uno
biol y una vez más el dios nos dice que
tenemos dos de los grupos hidroxilo
unidos a esto pero podrás ver el nombre
de esta molécula en cualquiera de estas
dos maneras